matic de gros 18 ans sébastien vigier 20
ans deux des plus grands espoirs du
cyclisme sur piste français en 2017 les
deux pépites ont tout raflé sur leur
passage cet été la jeune sprinteuse a
notamment réalisé le triplé aux
championnats de france élite
sébastien lui réussi plusieurs podiums
en coupe du monde une réussite qui ne
surprend pas les coaches de l'équipe de
france ils ont une envie de réussir qui
est vraiment au delà de la moyenne même
du groupe c'est vraiment quelque chose
c'est vraiment une grande exigence au
quotidien et c'est vrai que d'une
volonté de réussir que en ambre et
progresse très vite et ils atteignent
des niveaux en tout cas déjà dans leur
catégorie d'âge qui sont parmi les
meilleurs du monde une progression
fulgurante qui pourrait les emmener à
devenir les futurs stars de la
discipline en 2024 lors des jeux
olympiques de paris ouais bien sûr j'ai
vraiment envie d'y être c'est un peu on
va dire l'objectif d'une carrière mais
ça serait way bella projet de carrière
de participer au championnat devenant un
pic à paris pour l'instant je pense
plutôt court terme
c'est quand même dans huit ans donc non
je n'ai pas encore imaginer ça mais
peut-être bientôt ya énormément de
chemin et nature à lui ça fait que trois
ans que je fais du vélo du coup voilà je
sais que voilà j'ai tout gagné chez les
juniors mais je sais que la marche
juniors élite est très très très grande
et que encore pour être médaillés aux
jeux j'ai encore énormément de progrès à
faire que ce soit physique technique
tactique mais avant de penser aux
médailles d'or olympiques il faudra
passer encore de nombreuses heures à
s'entraîner sur la piste du bel automne
national de saint quentin en yvelines
il ya des étapes à franchir
il ya des formations affaires et les
résultats viendront avec le temps et
voilà tout et tout est planifié sur sur
une voire deux olympiades pour qu'ils
puissent être performant la prochaine
étape pour les deux pépites françaises
les championnats d'europe élite
programmée du 18 au 22 octobre à berlin
un rendez-vous mathilde et sébastien
espère briller